WILLIAM DRAWDOWN NESTS IS IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE ARE
SERIOUS PROSPECTS ABOUT LOSING
AMERICAN JOBS.
FIRST UP, MOLLY LINE IN
PENNSYLVANIA TONIGHT WHERE THEY
COULD BE LOOKING AT NEW JOBS.
GOOD EVENING, MOLLY.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
IMPRESSION CRITICS INCLUDING A
CHORUS OF VOICES FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S OWN PARTY HAVE
DECRIED HAS A STEEP TARIFFS ON
STEEL AND ALUMINUM.
MANY OF THOSE WHO STILL WORK AT
A DWINDLED NUMBER OF PLANTS HERE
IN PENNSYLVANIA FEEL HOPE.
>> I THINK IT'S AN EXTRA SHOT OF
THE ARM FOR US.
WE NEED ALL THE JOB SECURITY WE
CAN GET.
>> HE WORKS FOR YOU MUST DEAL IN
WEST MIDLAND AVENUE HE'S THE
PRESIDENT OF THE LOCAL
STEELWORKERS UNION.
HE BELIEVES THE PRESIDENT'S
TARIFF PLAN WILL GIVE THE
INDUSTRY A MUCH-NEEDED BOOST.
>> EVERY TIME WE GET A MOVE LIKE
THAT WITH EXTRA SECURITY, IT
BRINGS NEW HIGHER REASON.
IT CREATES A LOT OF JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE VALLEY.
>> HE TRAVELED TO WASHINGTON
TODAY TO WATCH THE PRESIDENT PUT
PEN TO PAPER.
HIS FAMILY, LIKE MANY STEEL
CLIENTS AMONG THE VALLEY,
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS TO HAVE
A GOOD JOB AND STEEL.
WHAT IT MEANS TO LOSE ONE, AS
HIS FATHER DID NEARLY 40 YEARS
AGO.
>> I NEVER FORGOT THAT, LOOKING
INTO HIS EYES, AND MY HOUSEHOLD,
WHAT THAT DOES TO A FAMILY.
YOU HEAR ABOUT IT, BUT WHEN YOU
ARE ACTUALLY INVOLVED IN IT, IT
IMPACTS YOU.
IT WILL NEVER LEAVE YOU.
>> IN THE WAKE OF WORLD WAR II'S
WAR MOBILIZATION, PENNSYLVANIA
STEEL INDUSTRY THRIVED, UNTIL
THE EARLY '80s.
AN UNPRECEDENTED GUSH OF CHEAP
FOREIGN STEEL FLOODED THE WORLD
MARKET AND LIKE DOMINOES, THE
PLANTS AND MALES LET OUT OF
THESE MOUNTAINS SHUT DOWN.
HIS DAD REMEMBERS THE SHATTERING
BLOW.
>> IT WAS A SHOCKING REALITY FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
MAYBE EIGHT OR 900 GUYS.
READY GOING OUT NOW?
SPOKE OF THE SIX SOVEREIGNS
WHOSE CARS, HOMES, AND
MARRIAGES, AND SAID THE REGION
IS NEVER RECOVERED.
>> THESE TOWNS HAVE TURNED INTO
GHOST TOWNS.
THE RUST BELT IS AMAZING.
NOW IT IS ALL DRUG-INFESTED.
IT'S HARD.
IT'S JUST A HARD PLACE TO TRY TO
LIVE AND SURVIVE.
>> BUT THIS FAMILY IS NOT GIVING
UP.
AND SCOTT BELIEVES THE FUTURE OF
STEEL IS STRONG.
>> MAYBE YOU'LL SEE SOMEBODY'S
CITIES AND TOWNS CLEAN UP
AND YOU'LL SEE PEOPLE WALK
AROUND WITH HOPE.
>> U.S. STEEL EMPLOYS MORE THAN
3,000 PEOPLE AND ITS FACILITIES
HERE IN THE VALLEY, THE
QUESTION, OF COURSE, IS WHETHER
THESE TARIFFS WILL MEAN NEW
JOBS.
A SPOKESPERSON SAYS THAT THEY DO
ANTICIPATED INCREASED DEMAND FOR